hello and welcome to this video playing
George Brassens whatever I do I'm
pronouncing this wrong there's no
absolute there's absolutely no way for
me to pronounce it correctly like for me
personally I'm not really good at
pronunciation anyway and that's probably
just wrong okay I'm trying to irritate
him with this line with Bishop g4 I
don't think people yes you know it and I
have to say oh no it well f3 is not I
think posing many problems but it's not
I don't know exactly how you continue
from here yeah okay this chick is
correct
you take twice but I'm not certain rupee
one as the move now
I think Bishop g6 this is all very draw
edge in fact I think ninety to one with
ten assists the more interesting move to
try to fight for something at least here
this is a almost forced draw computer
standard wise but I don't really know
exactly the lines I've looked at it once
but not entirely sure anymore I think
rupee one is what they usually do I came
the text see it takes the pawn so I'll
probably just take it
and c6 get this back bishop g6 next the
danger from God's point of view here is
that dangerous wrong but the thing is it
just it can happen that you can some
that you simply get the board gets
traded down to absolutely nothing
there's also what I think is a slight
drawback like from blacks point of view
in the line it's not bad this is Bishop
g4 line but it's very difficult to ever
win which is a common problem with the
black site of the Scotch for Knights
which is the reason why I do recommend
it with white and it's got four Knights
um you have to make some real really
substantial mistakes to be worse it's so
possible of course but it is an
extremely solid way of playing from
white what I'm trying here is to maybe
trade c7 for a - okay I have the outside
passer which is not a lot
okay
extremely dry wash this pollution
really let's see you can I want to move
the a porn but to prepare a little bit
better for it maybe rook c8 first okay I
take it rock shakes it's a pin there's a
pin my ticks it with the pawn okay but I
didn't think about
don't think it's particularly bad she's
like I haven't I did not think about the
move at all that this could be played
poor it's night before I move that
doesn't really do much I can just push
this and said
maybe Group C 2 could be irritating on
this one and now I'm on T 3 and night C
- maybe it's not a lot
still equal but maybe you can set some
problems
all right time time is ticking down for
white night see to night see to night
see - we had to go look for a 500 wins
material g5 is the the key point after
look at 4-4 g5 strapping the rook okay
so what is the quickest way probably the
apron and a2 a1 is unstoppable
no that was a surprisingly quick win
from a nothing position yeah that Bishop
g4 line is an interesting variation I
think that f3 is maybe almost it's a
draw by fossa from both sides play play
perfectly I think 92 was the best way to
continue to play f3 Bishop age 5 and she
took it if he does not take on c6 now
this whole f3 operation and didn't
really help all that much
you can play g4 first if you like but I
don't think that leads to anything
either
you know g6 is the way to play if you
once you have grabbed it so it's a case
of having said a you have to say beam
yeah
in for a penny in for a pound or what
what's the English one for that quince
is six and now I'm happy to trade off
the the pair of Bishops yeah this is
just an equal position I try to get
something going there with the a pawn
and really took them and allowed the
slight imbalance which is not a problem
at all I just take the I think and it
feels like if anybody I can try a little
bit yeah with the outside passer but
it's not very Josh very Josh this is now
getting a little bit uncomfortable the D
pawn is weak and the knight is good on
d5 Bishop deform probably not right with
EC 8s the best move okay
or one of the better moves let's say
yeah I'm threatening one c2 now
I will cp8 exceed or a3 was stronger
okay so what what is it that you should
have done it's interesting I take take
and group to a-1 okay yeah okay night c2
is nothing I can take on any form I now
look a aid but it's not so easy I'm
non-threatening this oh and I'm not
winning this year you can poke around
it's probably still draw yeah okay the
way it turned out he was blundering into
into this thing and now I'm winning
easily okay guys thanks a lot for
watching